okay well I don't want to you know get
too cheesy here to start with but I do
have to begin by wishing a happy
birthday to a very special person this
is someone who I love deeply someone who
coming they're gonna be embarrassed by
this but but honestly someone who is
just really smart and generous funny
kind extremely good-looking maybe the
best person in the world this is someone
who means the world to me so happy
birthday to me it's my birthday I turned
33 today it's it's no big deal you know
I don't want you I don't want you think
it's a big deal like it's don't even
don't even worry but it's not like you
guys have to you know send me presents
and money or anything like that I I
wouldn't want that I mean I take the
presents and money if you send them to
me I would take them but but don't don't
feel like you have to do that it's you
know it's it's it's it's really no big
deal
it's just a birthday so forget I said
anything but you know it is my birthday
that that's all I'm saying it's just
that's all that's all I'm trying to tell
you okay Harvard has rescinded its
acceptance of a prominent gun rights
activist Kyle cashew and we're gonna
we're going to talk about that in just a
minute but but first I have to let you
know that today's podcast is brought to
you by VIN chair o watches no matter
what you consider your style to be if
you if you have a style you know
sometimes I don't even know what my
style is but I do know that I like a
quality classic wristwatch and I think
that's something that every guy needs
there's always going to be an occasion
where you want to look sharp and impress
I was at a wedding over the weekend and
so that's an occasion where maybe you
don't want to have that Apple watch
which is just like a computer you know
attached to your wrist maybe you want
the the style and the clasp of a watch
we're partnering with partnering with
VIN sharrows so you can get a truly
stunning watch at an even more
impressive price exclusively for our
listeners Bench arrow is offering an
extra 15% off their exceptionally
crafted watches go to vin cheerio
watches dot-com forward slash Walsh and
use code walls to save an extra 15%
that's VI NC er o watches comm forward
slash Walsh code Walsh for 15% off that
was our first time working with of and
share oh and the guys were nice enough
to send me
one of their watches which I have right
here and I really love this watch me
makes it somehow it makes me look good
which is quite quite impressive I've
been wearing the chrono s matte gray
this is what I have been where I've been
wearing it non-stop gotten complimented
every time I've worn it so it really is
just a great good looking eye catching
watch the Cheerios strive to be the best
best value in the industry and I believe
they are you're not going to find a
better watch for this good of a price
anywhere else and I'm not alone just
head to VIN chair oh the cheras website
read all of the five star reviews
they've received just trust what the
customers are telling you as I said I'm
wearing the chrono S matte gray but then
Cheryl has dozens of watches to choose
from I went ahead and picked my top five
you can go to the chera watches dot-com
forward slash Walsh to see my picks and
don't forget to use code walls for 15%
off these watches already look way more
expensive than they are which means when
you user 15% off you're getting one hell
of a deal on that so go to VI and see
ero watches comm forward slash Walsh
code Walsh for 15% off all right um as
you may have heard yesterday parklands
shooting survivor gun rights advocate
Kyle cashews Harvard Harvard admission
has been rescinded he had been accepted
in Harvard now that's being taken away
that's what her sended me indicate guess
you didn't know over comments that he
made privately to his friends when he
was 16 years old and the comments in
question I'm not going to repeat them
here because I I can't just suffice it
to say if you haven't seen them they are
gross stupid racist but they were also
the comments of a high school boy joking
around with his buddies and trying to be
as shocking and outrageous as possible
it's pretty obvious to me when you see
the comments that that's what they're
doing now teenage boys are known to do
that I don't mean to scandalize you if
you weren't aware of this but boys
especially at the age of 15 or 16 this
is what they do they they say the most
outrageous and offensive things that
they can think of to each other
privately now he was not a public figure
at the time and he
would have had no idea that a couple of
years later he would be in the limelight
due to a massacre at his school this was
not as a sixteen-year-old kid that was
not anywhere on his radar any more than
it would be on any of our radars now he
has apologized first comments which were
leaked to the media in a transparent
effort to destroy him for his second
Amendment advocacy and since taking on
this new role as a gun rights champion
he hasn't said or done anything to
demonstrate racism so when he says that
he's changed and that he's not the same
person that he was when he was 16 well
there's no evidence to dispute that
claim because he hasn't done or said
anything since we've known about him to
indicate racism also we know that in
between the age of 16 and right now he
was he did experience a traumatic event
a school shooting is a traumatic event
and those kinds of events can have
transformative effects on people so when
he says I've changed in the meantime
there's nothing absurd or unbelievable
about that
in fact it'd be kind of unbelievable if
he hadn't changed considering what he
went through during the shooting but
despite his efforts to repair whatever
damage the gross jokes he told to his
friends you know might have done to the
people who were exposed to them two
years later because of a coordinated
effort to destroy his reputation
whatever damage that might have done and
despite his apology for that he was
still punished anyway I think this move
by Harvard is Craven it's nakedly
partisan every sane person knows that
Kyle's affiliation with the conservative
movement weighed heavily against him
what his omission had been revoked
had he been an anti Second Amendment
advocate like like his classmate David
Hogg well we can't know that for sure
but we have reasons to be suspicious and
the reason we have to be suspicious is
that we know the rules are not applied
equally so one example people have been
using which i think is a good example is
you take the governor
Virginia now the governor of Virginia
his uh you know he had College yearbook
photos which surfaced months ago showing
somebody in blackface and somebody in a
KKK hood and he originally said oh now
remember what he the way he originally
responded to that was he said he wasn't
sure like he wasn't sure which one who
if he was in the picture who he was yeah
maybe he wrote wore a Klan outfit maybe
he wore black cuz he wasn't sure now me
I can say definitively that I have never
worn a Klan outfit or black because I
you know I can say that because I would
remember doing that
the fact that Northam couldn't remember
would seem to indicate maybe that either
he's lying or he dressed that way so
often that he can't remember who he was
in the picture but then later he denied
it but then he came out and said okay
well I wasn't that guy but I did wear
blackface at another point when I was
dressing up like Michael Jackson for a
talent show
he said he's he's he smeared shoe polish
on his face to look like Michael Jackson
yet Northam is still governor despite
the fact that he engaged in racist
behavior and that he engaged in that
racist behavior in his 20s when he was
adult an adult he's still the governor
of Virginia now if you want to miss the
point which a lot of people do these
days you could argue that well these two
cases are unrelated the the Harvard
admissions office has nothing to do with
the governorship of Virginia right
governor you know it's not like the
people at Harvard can revoke or rescind
the governorship from from Northam also
governorships are a lot harder to revoke
from someone then would be the excited
their acceptance to it to a college but
that's not the point
Harvard made its decision because of the
relentless pressure placed on it by
leftists and the media Northam on the
other hand survived his racism scandal
because there was not that kind of
pressure
now in the first couple
of days after the blackface photo came
out you did have Democrats issuing
statements and condemning North them and
so on and so forth but you notice that
you know within two or three days they
moved on and they don't talk about it
and where the media doesn't bring it up
they don't bring it up they don't talk
about it why is that well I think number
one it's because he's a Democrat but
also when when the when the blackface
photo scandal first started and
Democrats were issuing statements well
they thought that okay we'll just get
rid of this guy the lieutenant governor
is is also a Democrat so we'll just get
him in there also lieutenant governor is
a younger guy is a black guy we'd prefer
him over North America then it comes out
that the Lieutenant Governor is multiply
accused incredibly accused of rape and
then the third in command the Attorney
General comes out admits that that he
also dressed in blackface as a as a
younger man so then Democrats start
realizing that wait a second you know if
we get rid of Northam for blackface well
then we also got rid of gotta get rid of
the Attorney General for blackface and
then we've got this lieutenant governor
who's accused of rape who knows where
that's gonna go fourth in command is a
Republican so you know we don't want to
we're just gonna forget about we're
gonna drop this and forget about it
that's why they moved on because they
never cared about the blackface thing
they never cared about the racism it was
all self-serving and then they realized
that it's not in their best interest
actually to get rid of Northam the best
thing is just to move on from this and
pretend it never happened and that's
what they've been doing so it is a
selective outrage of course now if we
were interested in developing a more
consistent approach to these kinds of
controversies which I know a lot of
people are not interested in that but if
we were I would suggest that we take a
few things into consideration any time
we have one of these controversies or
scandals where offensive stuff from
someone's past comes up I think we
should take a few things in
consideration number one how old was the
person when they did or said the offense
of thing number two did they do or say
the offensive thing publicly number
three were they public figures when they
did or said the offensive thing Kyle was
16 he said or wrote actually the things
privately he was not a public figure all
three of these factors in my mind would
seem the call for grace and forgiveness
Northam was an adult his behavior was
not private he did it in a talent show
by his own admission but he wasn't a
public figure at the time either and it
happened a long while ago so I can see
an argument for letting Northam off the
hook on this one but I can't see an
argument for letting North mouth milk
while holding Kyle to account it seems
that that you only have the intellectual
credibility to call for forgiveness for
Northam if you also call for forgiveness
for Kyle there's no reasonable argument
that can make Kyle the bigger bad guy
here you see that's the problem now for
another comparison consider Samantha B
and Roseanne okay be called Ivanka Trump
a feckless c-word on her show Roseanne
compared Valerie Jarrett to the Planet
of the Apes both of these women are
adults both made their comments publicly
as adults in front of millions of people
both were public figures at the time
that they made their comments both
should have known better both put their
employers in a in a difficult position
by their own choices so there's a
reasonable argument in fire in favor of
firing both of them there is no
reasonable argument in favor of firing
Roseanne but not Samantha bee yet again
that's exactly what happened
Roseanne was punished her careers
destroyed kicked off her show which was
the number one show on TV Samantha bee
is even though nobody watches her show
in the first place and nobody cares
about her she still didn't lose her job
and her career is not destroyed if
anything she actually benefited from
that and and she has more credibility
and street cred among leftist so why is
that well of course because bees a liver
roseann is actually liberal - but she's
considered a conservative by default
because she likes Trump and that's
that's all that matters in the end
really that's all that matters but you
know I think as I as I've thought more
about this with Kyle you know I'm
talking about his age and the fact that
he wasn't a public figure so on and so
forth I think that's that is part of the
point but maybe that's not even the main
point here because I'm thinking over the
last day I know that the situation with
Kyle having is his acceptance revoked
it makes me very uncomfortable and I'm
trying to figure I'm trying to put my
finger on what exactly makes me so
uncomfortable about it I've already
mentioned a few of the things and I know
any liberal who's watching well it's
only because he's a conservative that's
why you're on cut you wouldn't care if
he was a liberal that's just not true
you know I Roseanne as I said I when
Roseanne was fired I said that she
probably deserved it so I don't make
these I don't personally I don't judge
these things on a partisan basis I don't
care about that I'm looking for a more
consistent way to evaluate these kinds
of cases so the the thing aside from age
and all of that because I agree that the
age excuse does seem on the surface kind
of weak considering he was 16 at the
time but he's 18 now so it's not like
this was 25 s not like he's 30 now and
it was he was 16 at the time or 40 that
was only two years ago but the gap
between 16 and 18 is actually very
significant or can be it's much bigger
than the gap between 33 and 31 between
16 and 18 because of in that age you're
just growing a lot you know
physiologically there's there a lot of
changes happening and so someone can
have a transformative change between 16
and 18 whereas between 40 and 42 that's
gonna be a lot less likely because
you're kind of stuck in your ways at
that point but you're not at 16
especially when you undergo it format
experience in the middle of that but
that's not really the point the point is
this the sorts of people who dig up dirt
against their political or personal
rivals should not get their way the only
reason we know about this with Kyle is
because these private conversations were
leaked and they were leaked by I guess
friends who don't like him anymore
because of his political advocacy and
they were and and it was it was these
messages were taken and in amplified by
dirt merchants in the media and others
who again are trying to destroy Kyle
because they don't like his politics and
that to me is very relevant you know I
think the court of public opinion should
in this regard operate a lot like a
court of law where we should treat
ill-gotten evidence as inadmissible now
I know it doesn't work that way because
the court of public opinion is not a
court of law but I'm saying in this
particular situation I think it should
if we only know about something because
of a smear campaign against someone
where private conversations are being
leaked in order to destroy them I think
again I know it will never happen but I
think what we should do is say it's you
know what I don't want to hear that we
have no business hearing that that's why
I never actually thought that Northam
should resign for the blackface photo I
thought he should resign for publicly
advocating infanticide when he was an
adult and governor not something that he
did on the radio as a governor now that
we could hold him accountable for but we
should be very wary of dirt dug up from
the past because when the target of a
smear campaign is destroyed
it's the dirt merchants who win not just
this not tolerance not inclusivity raw
vengeance and opportunism that's what
wins the day and I consider that a loss
so
think about Kyle having his Harvard
acceptance revoked
who wins well the people who leaked this
stuff and tried to destroy them destroy
him
they're the ones who win and I don't I
don't see how that's a win for society
or for our culture or for anyone except
for those people I think it's best for
society when smear merchants and dirt
merchants lose I think it would be best
for society when the dirt merchants come
with dirt and they say look at his dirt
we dug up on this guy and the rest of us
go yeah you know what I don't care
that's you know we had that's that
wasn't meant for our ears we weren't
meant to see that and if you think that
sounds unreasonable well well how do you
respond how should you respond and if
you think that sounds unreasonable well
how how would you respond or how should
you respond if a gossip comes up to you
and your person just on a personal level
let's say someone you know who's very
gossipy comes up to you and says hey
you're never gonna believe hey guess
what I found out about you know
so-and-so it guess what they said to
someone else
two years ago get listen to this I got
some dirt on this but you want to hear
this now if you're someone who likes to
engage in gossip you might say oh yeah
give me the dirt let me hear this this
sounds good but I think we all know that
the proper response to that is to say I
don't want to hear it don't tell me it's
not relevant to me you have no business
telling me that I'm not going to engage
in gossip I don't want to hear it I
think most of us know
how we should respond to gossip is I
don't wanna even if it's true
gossip doesn't always mean that it's
lies or it's not true it could could be
true but most of us understand even if
we don't follow through all the time
most of us understand that the way to
respond to gossips is to shut them down
and say I don't want to hear it I'm not
having this conversation and so I think
on a public level what we should do
basically the same thing and say I don't
want to hear that and that's so that's
that's what it comes down to for me is I
don't like the fact that we are
emboldened people like this all right
here's here's something else famous
murderer Oh Jay Simpson is out of jail
now and and on Twitter if you didn't
hear he sent out a tweet a few days ago
announcing his arrival to the platform
and everyone responded with disgust Oh
people say oh this is so gross OJ
Simpson is tweeting now should be in
prison this is disgusting you know that
Twitter is a cesspool it's what everyone
said but here we are two or three days
later and it will come as no surprise
that OJ is still tweeting and he now
tweets to 700,000 followers so while
everyone pretended to be disgusted by OJ
on Twitter 700,000 of those people
decided to follow him and and think
about what following someone on Twitter
means it means that every time you sign
on to Twitter you want to see what this
person is saying right you want to
follow them around in cyberspace and
hear everything they're saying whatever
thoughts happen to pop into their head
you you want to hear it whatever comes
in their mind you won't have immediate
access to it you want those thoughts
posted in your feed so that you can see
them right away a short cut and 700,000
people so far want that kind of
says to OJ Simpson a man who at this
point is oh now he's a famous football
player before this he was in Hollywood
for a while but the only reason he's
really famous now when you hear OJ
Simpson first thing you're thinking is
that he decapitated two people and and
that's what people want her to follow
this guy I just only reason I bring this
up I just can't think of a better and it
kind of relates to what I was just
talking about really I can't think of a
better encapsulation of our culture than
this and where everyone pretends I uh
I'm so al azhar jo j simpson i'm so
outraged this guy and then and then all
these people go is like yeah but i'll
follow him anyway you know I mentioned
this on Twitter a couple days ago and
people tell me well I I follow him so
that I can be up to speed or I follow
him so that I can see what crazy and
stupid things he's tweeting and you see
that's exactly the problem first of all
why do you need to be up to speed on
what OJ Simpson is saying we've got this
culture now of people feeling like they
need to be in the loop no matter what
the loop is never stopping to think is
this a loop that I actually need to be
in or want to be in how is my life gonna
be enriched by this how is this actually
gonna make my day better or or my life
better we've got this obsession with
being informed that without any care for
the relevance or the quality or
importance of that information that's
one of the reasons why when people talk
all the times well we need to be more
informed people aren't informed enough
know people are informed enough people
are informed too much probably we live
in the most informed civilization ever
in history without a doubt I mean people
have access to tons of information and
people have tons of information bouncing
around their heads the problem is that
most of that information is useless and
pointless and there's no reason why
anyone needs to know it and the problem
also is that we have in
formation we are informed rather than
being knowledgeable and smart because
there's a difference between having
knowledge and having information and
then and then people say well I want to
see crazy and stupid stuff that he
tweets well why though this this is a
this is a very unhealthy impulse that we
have and it seems to be an insatiable
appetite that we have for this way well
I I want to have I want to see all the
crazy and stupid stuff do you not do you
really not already have enough crazy and
stupid in your life isn't there enough
crazy and stupid out there you could
turn on the TV any time and see crazy
and stupid you can go anywhere on the
internet and see crazy and stupid
there's crazy you you can you can walk
outside of your house and see crazy and
stupid you can maybe even look in the
mirror if you're me and see crazy and
stupid so you could see crazy and stupid
anywhere do you really need more of it
but it really is an insatiable addiction
we have so oh there's more more crazy
and stupid I need more yes more and more
and more we see we see another source of
crazy and stupid and we've got to get
our fix we just need that we need to
surround ourselves by it all the time
why is that I don't get it
well I do kind of get it I think it's um
I think we want a lot of crazy and
stupid in our life because number one
it's just distraction and it prevents us
from having to think or contemplate
anything and I think number two it makes
us feel better about ourselves it makes
us feel smarter it makes us feel more
sane more rational but that's the thing
is it really smart sane or rational to
go seeking crazy and stupid stuff and
immerse yourself in it no you see that
is both crazy and stupid
so in our F
to make ourselves feel better for not
being crazy and stupid we have actually
become crazy and stupid that's the moral
of the story sounds like a Aesop's fable
or something like that okay I have one
more thing to mention here if I can I'm
just stalling for a minute as I as I
pull it up okay here we go so on the
website queer t-dot-com that's the name
of the website not a website I check
very often but it's been it's been this
this certain article has been all over
social media the headline of the article
is Transpo's Charles rearranges the
alphabet to survive its ferocity
ferocity against her body I feel like I
should read that against because it
might have been confusing trans poet
Joss Charles rearranges the alphabet to
survive its ferocity against her body
and and then this is so it's an article
about this poet who is rearranging the
alphabet I'll read a little bit of the
of the article for you speaking of crazy
and stupid you see all the topics now
are just blending into each other this
is this is pretty it's pretty good what
I'm doing I hope you appreciate it says
Charles has reworked the structure of
language to capture the trans experience
establishing her as one of the most
promising poets of her generation
Charles combines a deep understanding of
poetic traditions with her own personal
experience to create works that address
gender and identity issues in a unique
and moving way her second volume of
poetry field name of the name of the
poetry book is field that's F EE LD not
felt field creates a language resembling
middle English to challenge our limited
vocabulary to describe the trans
experience in the process Charles has
won praise as one of the most important
young poets today and the appropriate
recognition field was chosen by the New
Yorker as one of the best poetry books
of 2018
to challenges readers and not just
because of the language it is at once
lyrical and pointed here here's a couple
of lines they give us from the poetry
book here's here's a line
did you know not a month goes by a Tran
I know doesn't die and that's you
spelled with just the letter you know
spelled KN Oh a month spelled mo and th
e and bye spelled B ye and then some
more lyrics here gender is not the Tran
or game gender is yes ahem oh reg glad
just that doesn't mean anything
that's just that's just literally just
nonsense out of gender spelled GE n dr e
or gain spelled oor GA any I don't even
know I don't know what that word it this
is a made-up word and anyway it's a it
it goes on from there you know that this
is there's so much that it can be said
about this or maybe there's not much
it's just it's just utter nonsense but
you see a few things happening here
number one we see the continued
disintegration of language of poetry of
art where something like this this
gimmicky ridiculous nonsensical garbage
is named you know one of the poetry or
this person put one of the poets of the
year poetry of the year or whatever it
was but you also find here's what jumps
out at me is it we can't lose sight of
this it's the incredible arrogance of
this person of
of the left especially of gay activists
trans activists this person is saying oh
you know what the regular language isn't
good enough for me regular languages of
word and English languages it just
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't capture my
experience my experience is so
transcendent and so beautiful it's a so
deep and perplexing and wonderful that
this is there there's just no I have to
invent new words for it and he and even
regular words that already exist you
know that it's beneath me to use those
words I'm going I'm gonna I'm gonna
rearrange the letters because it that's
just that's that's that's that's for
that's for the plebs you know that's
that's for the that's for the peasants
to use word regular words that I I need
new words that's really what's going on
here it's just incredible arrogance that
you find I'm so constrained by the
alphabet you know I have lived my whole
I've lived 30 - well now 33 years of
life because it is my birthday by the
way I don't know if I mentioned that
I've lived 33 years of life and I have
been able to express everything I've
wanted to express using the regular
alphabet and regular words I saw and
just everyone I know has been able to do
that almost everyone in the world has
been able to do that and but not you of
course you need you need special words
you need special words now because
everything needs to be special for you
because you're so special all right
let's move on to some emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com this is from Peter says Matt I
think I caught you in an inconsistency
you say that you think people have the
right to burn the flag because it's free
speech but you've also previously said
that you think pornography should be
banned I know those two things are not
the same but how can you be a free
speech advocate with one and not the
other yesterday it seemed like you were
taking a free speech absolutist position
but your previous statements reveal that
you are not a free speech absolutist how
do you explain the contradiction yeah we
talked about yesterday about the burning
flag issue I said it's free speech I
have said in the past
I think porn should be banned so that's
a good point you know that's a that's a
good thing to bring up
did you catch me in a contradiction I
don't think you did and let me let me
explain the difference I think when
deciding whether something is covered by
free speech we need to consider two
things all right number one is the thing
in question speech okay in order for it
to be free speech it has to actually be
speech is the primary point of the thing
in question to convey a coherent message
right that's what speech is that's me is
speech it is conveying a message that's
speech so if someone is arrested for you
know for instance urinating in public
well they can't claim free speech
because the primary point of urinating
is not to convey a message okay you're
not trying to get a message across when
you're doing that you're just doing it
because you have to so that's not free
speech it is speech in my mind even if
it doesn't involve spoken or written
words if the people who witness it can
see it and say okay okay yeah I get the
message so that's why I think burning
the flag is speech but we'll get to that
a second so in the second thing you
could take into consideration is does
the speech in question cause real active
harm to other people so this is why
slander is illegal because yeah slander
is speech a conveys message but the
point of the speech is to cause direct
and intentional harm to another person
and so that's why it's illegal
okay now let's let's apply this is
burning a flag speech yes I think
obviously it is we all know it is
because that's exactly why people are
against it you're against it because you
hate the message that it sends is what
explaining yesterday now if you see
someone burning a flight it's it's not
the simple act of burning a flag that
you oppose right because you could burn
a flag for good reasons you could be
disposing of the flag that's a proper
way to dispose of a flag so it's not the
burning of the flag you have a problem
with it's the message that's being sent
that's what you have a problem with and
that's what everyone says everyone says
oh you know you burning the flag and
says it's a symbol of your showing
ingratitude you're a disgrace to our
country you're spitting all over the
sacrifice that our troops made I agree
that yes that's what it does but solely
but you get the message right so it is
conveying a message you clearly
understand the message now I don't agree
with the message it's a bad message is a
stupid message it's an offensive mess
but it is a message so it is speech in
the same way on the opposite end if
someone flies a flag we all understand
the message they're sending they're
saying I love America I'm proud to be an
American we all get that we know that's
the message we all understand that
burning the flag is the opposite message
we all get that - is pornography speech
I would say no what message is being
conveyed by two people having sex if you
watch a guy burn a flag for two seconds
you know exactly what he's trying to say
if you see two people having sex
what are they saying what message are
they trying to send you what ideas are
they expressing now you might say that
there's sexual relations in the couple
the people having sex are conveying a
message to each other but that's not
pornography pornography involves the
third party witness right so what
message is being conveyed to that third
party witness I would say there is no
real message and if you say that porn is
speech then you also have to say that
prostitution is speech but prostitution
is illegal almost everywhere in the
country and most people agree unless
you're a hardcore libertarian you agree
the prostitution should be illegal what
poor
prostitution are the exact same thing
it's transactional sex and it's sex for
money which is transactional sex
that's what pornography is that's what
prostitution is the only difference
between prostitution and pornography is
that in pornography the prostitutes are
being filmed so I mean if you film a
prostitute is it all of a sudden not
prostitution anymore because you're
filming it that's absurd obviously it's
prostitution because you're paying the
person to have sex in pornography these
are people who are being paid to have
sex or are even if they're not being
directly paid they're somehow probably
gaining money from it profiting from it
somehow so that's why I think it's not
speech
it's prostitution and prostitution is
not speech it's a transaction and that's
not necessarily the same thing
number two harm what harm does burning a
flag caused to any person provided it's
done safely it doesn't start a forest
fire what harm is done um if you see a
person burning a flag it makes you angry
you're upset by it you oppose it does it
harm you I mean are you really
traumatized by it I'd be honest like you
see a guy burning a flag I know it
really pisses you off as well it should
all right is it gonna affect the rest of
your you'll be so traumatized by that by
witnessing that you barely move on with
your life no it doesn't it doesn't
traumatize people doesn't scandalize the
public it doesn't cause people to become
anti-american in fact if anything it
galvanizes people in the opposite
direction to defend America whereas with
pornography I would argue that it
absolutely does cause real harm
especially to kids kids suffer real
trauma from their exposure to
pornography it causes real damage
psychologically to people it has a real
effect on your brain which is lasting
and that's the same
of the harm the porn industry does to
those in it when you look at the suicide
rate the drug abuse rate the sed rate
within the porn world you see that it
causes a lot of harm to everybody
involved and so that's why I think you
could argue for banning pornography but
not flag-burning
alright this is from Maggie says hi my
name is Maggie I'm an eighteen year old
from Wyoming I'm a new listener and the
first show of yours that I happened upon
was one in which you claimed that adding
sour cream 2 eggs was the best way to
achieve the perfect breakfast I didn't
realize I didn't believe this in the
slightest but after listening to a few
more of your shows I realized that I
agree with you and almost everything
else decided that your culinary options
opinions may also be something that I
agree with after trying it I concede
that you are the supreme leader in the
kitchen as well keep up the good work
this is from Dallas Matt I'm always
looking for better recipes so I tried
your scrambled eggs recipe the other day
you know that I heard on your show I
don't know if you came up with that
yourself or not but I don't think I'll
ever find a better plate of scrambled
eggs in the glorious manna
I just finished eating thank you so much
for sharing that if you have any more
gems like that one I'd love to hear them
this is from Bryan
salutations future a theocratic dictator
overlord of this realm in any other
realm and had a little inhabitable by
human beings I want to start this email
out by saying that I have no culinary
experience whatsoever I'm a notorious
egg burner after listening to your
podcast and your recipe for fluffy
scrambled eggs I decided to give it a
shot I went to the grocery store picked
up butternut milk and sour cream I did
everything according to your explanation
and Eureka breakfast was served and it
was amazing
I managed to not burn the eggs and ruin
Sunday breakfast as well my girlfriend
and I started calling the recipe huevos
alla Walsh anyway thank you again and
keep up the amazing podcast those are
just that's a small sample of the emails
that I got extolling the virtues of my
scrambled eggs egg recipe which I shared
on the show a couple days ago and if you
missed it you have to go back and and
find it but I really did I think I did
change a lot of people's lives
because so many people have been making
scrambled eggs incorrectly and
humiliating themselves and all of
mankind by serving up burnt crispy
disgusting flakes of eggs that they call
scrambled eggs
no fluffiness no flavor so many people
have been doing this so I decided to
finally share the proper scrambled eggs
recipe and anyway those are just some of
the reviews that's all alright let's do
one more this is from jasmine says Matt
since you're a Christian I wanted to I
wanted to ask you a question that's been
Doug nagging me as you may know in acts
4:32 through 35 it says now the
multitude of those who believed were of
one heart and one soul neither did
anyone say that any of the things he
possessed was his own but they had all
things in common and with great power
the Apostles gave witness to the
resurrection of the Lord Jesus and great
grace was upon them all nor was there
any one among them who lacked for all
who were pizzette possessors of lands or
houses sold them and brought the
proceeds of the things that were sold
and laid them at the Apostles feet and
they distributed to each as anyone had
need although I am a capitalist I read
this and see the redistribution of
wealth in the early church does this
mean that the Bible advocates for
socialism jasmin no that doesn't mean
that it's socialism because notice one
element at play choice
the early Christians chose to live that
way this is not socialism that's the
opposite of socialism socialism is is
compelled by the state the state comes
in takes charge takes what it wants
redistributes that's what socialism is
all about what you find there are people
who choose to live a certain way
personally I'm a huge critic of
socialism but I think it's great when
people share when they help less
fortunate when they give to charity when
they live simple lives I'm a big fan of
that but I just think people should
choose that and so that is that's free
market it's free
people are living how they want to live
doing what they want with their own
money
um by the way why doesn't the Bible call
for a giant welfare state well I think
for one thing God knows that the
government that governments are corrupt
and so when you give them too much money
and too much power horrible things are
going to happen as we as we have seen
play out with socialist governments over
the last 100 years or so but even more
importantly what's the point of sharing
what's the point of giving to the less
fortunate what's the point of helping
those in need is the point to cure
poverty well no because Jesus said we're
always going to have the poor with us in
fact even encourage people to be poor so
I don't think Jesus saw poverty as
necessarily a problem that had to be
solved yet he did tell us to give to the
poor
so how do you how do you square that
well I think that um the answer is love
right that's really the point when you
stop on the street and you give some
food to a homeless person yeah he gains
a meal okay and which is a very
practical and necessary and good thing
something that he needs to live but he
also benefits from the act of love you
are extending a hand you are lifting him
up you are noticing him as a human being
you are making him feel more human and
in turn he makes you feel more human by
accepting your charity graciously and
with gratitude and I think that's the
real point that love is the point the
point is to love your fellow man to let
them know that they are loved to build
them up with love and and that's it and
that is lost that's completely lost when
the government doesn't because nobody
feels loved by the government nobody is
humanized by the government nobody is
lifted up by the government the opposite
is true to the government you're a
number you're a figure you're a tested
so that's why one of the reasons why
people get stuck on welfare and never
get off of it because it's dehumanizing
it's depressing it's it's it just makes
you feel like like a number just they
throw an EBT card at you they think they
they said you check whatever they don't
care about you you're dealing with
bureaucrats and bureaucracy doesn't care
about you doesn't look at you like a
person isn't concerned about you yet an
individual person who chooses to help
you well that is someone who's that that
is when you feel the love as it has it
work so I think that's the difference
and we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed hey
everyone on Andrew Klavan host of the
Andrew Clavin show what Harvard did to
pro-freedom activist Kyle cash of sucks
and if you make excuses for Harvard you
suck but then the truth is Harvard isn't
Harvard anymore just like the New York
Times isn't the times and Disney isn't
Disney these once great institutions are
just the skins of their former selves
being worn by an alien being named
leftism we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin